-Our next guest is a talented
actress you know from her work
on shows such as "Mad Men"
and
"Chilling Adventures of
Sabrina."
She stars in
"Swimming With Sharks,"
which is available on
the Roku channel.
Let's take a look.
-There are stories of love
inspiring success over
the most insurmountable odds.
Empowering stories,
where we're not crucifying
one another,
but playing fair.
♪♪
This...
[ Growling ]
...is not one of those stories.
-Please welcome back to the
show, Kiernan Shipka, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you?
-Hello! Oh, my goodness.
I'm well. How are you?
-I'm doing very well.
-It's been so long.
-It's lovely to have you here.
Last time you were here, we were
talking about "Sabrina."
-We were.
We were chatting 'Brina.
-And this is now --
this is a lot darker
than the world of 'Brina.
-Ooh, I know.
Not a witch anymore.
-Not a witch anymore.
But somehow not a witch --
so it takes place in Hollywood,
and it's way darker than
witchcraft.
-Yeah, yeah, way more evil.
-So you play an intern
who's working for a sort of
high-powered Hollywood
executive.
-I do.
-Do you like the darkness of
this material?
-I love it.
I don't know if I gravitate
toward dark material
or if it just finds me.
-Yeah.
-But it's my favorite to do.
I love being stoic.
I love having a secret.
-Oh, yeah.
And you do have a secret
in this.
-Yeah, she's got a lot of stuff
going on up here.
-Yeah.
-Less dialogue than Sabrina.
I was coming off of 10 months
of a ton of exposition
and saving the world.
-Yeah.
And Sabrina had to do
a lot of spells.
-She did.
A lot of Latin.
-A lot of Latin work
for an actor,
never fun to have to learn
Latin spells.
-No. No.
That's not what you sign up for.
-Exactly.
-But you do it anyway.
-You do it anyway.
-Yeah.
-And the other --
speaking of secrets, you know,
I was first introduced to you
in "Mad Men."
And the thing about "Mad Men"
that was interesting is
I feel like all the adults
in the show had secrets.
You probably didn't have many
secrets in that show.
-As a person, not as Sally.
-As a character, yeah, yeah.
-Yes, also, yeah,
as a character.
Yeah, she was learning
everything for the first time.
-A lot of people, I feel like,
during the pandemic
went back and watched that show.
-Mm-hmm.
-Were you one of those people?
-I was, actually.
-Okay.
-It was probably the first time
I truly sat down and binged
the whole thing.
-I mean, it makes sense.
-I watched "Sopranos" first.
-Okay.
-And then I thought,
"What next?"
-Yeah.
-I guess, "Mad Men."
And I did it.
-I mean, it makes sense.
You weren't really --
it was not a show that was,
like, age-appropriate for you
when you were starring in it.
-No, no, not for 6-year-olds.
-Yeah.
Everybody says
you want to be like, 8
before you start "Mad Men."
-Honestly, 12, I think,
is the sweet spot.
-Yeah, 12.
That's good that you can now
speak to it and be like, "12."
-Exactly.
But it was great.
I felt like I was watching it
and I'm a fan of the show.
-Did you ever, like,
forget something
that you had done on the show?
Like did you see yourself
in a scene?
-My memory was jogged. My memory
was always kind of jogged.
And I would sort of have an
association with the day, too.
-Yeah.
-I would say,
"Oh, I had that sort of moment
outside of set after I --"
-That's a cool thing,
to be able to revisit that
and find that stuff.
-Yeah.
-On this show,
playing an intern,
sort of Hollywood
assistant world.
-Yeah.
-A lot of being on calls,
being on e-mails.
-Right, right, right.
-Are you, in real life,
are you an organized person?
-No, I've got 3,000 e-mails
in my inbox.
-No!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No!
-And a lot of unread texts.
But something horrible happened.
I learned that I had read
receipts on,
and I didn't know that I did,
so --
-Oh, God. So for, like, years,
people have seen it?
-I don't know how long, Seth.
I don't know.
-Well, if you don't remember
turning it on,
that means it's probably
always been on.
-It could have been.
It's really bad.
But, no, I have a lot of e-mails
in my inbox
that are not answered.
-That's alright.
-But a lot of them
are just spam.
A lot of them are from, like,
a protein bar.
-Yeah, some of them are probably
from family.
-Close, close family, yeah.
-Yeah, or emergencies.
-Emergencies, yeah.
-Things that I should really
respond to.
-I have heard tell that your
grandmother is very invested
in her social media life.
-She's big on it.
She was very mad when Instagram
started hiding likes.
-Okay.
-Because that was a really big
source of joy,
was when my photos --
she would tell me
which photos were doing well.
-Gotcha.
-And which were not.
[ Laughter ]
-So she would post
a photo of you?
-No, she would look at mine.
-Oh.
-And she would see how much
engagement they were getting.
-That's great.
-Just to keep tabs on it,
I guess.
-That's better than if your
grandmother was out there,
like, posting her own stuff.
I think that's really adorable.
-I think she kind of has
a burner account.
I don't think she posts anything
for herself.
-Very advanced,
for your grandmother
to have a burner account.
-Exactly.
Yeah, I don't think she's
publicizing her life.
-This is not a member of your
family, but I believe someone
as close as family is
Timothée Chalamet.
-Ah, yes, Mr. Chalamet,
we love him.
He's like family.
He's like an honorary Shipka.
-How did he come into
the Shipka clan?
-Into the Shipka-verse?
We did a movie together.
-Okay.
-When I was 14,
and he must have been maybe 18
at the time.
-Okay.
-And ever since then,
has just kind of been, like,
a bro.
Sometimes would stay at our
house in L.A.
when he didn't have
a place to stay.
My mom would drive him to
auditions.
-That's very nice.
-Yeah.
Back in the day.
-He's got a license now,
I heard.
-Yeah, exactly.
He is driving.
-Things are going pretty well
for Chalamet.
-And a direct offer or two
as well.
-Is it true that you once
brought him on a date,
you third-wheeled him on a date?
-Well, okay,
so here's the thing.
It was sort of a date.
It was a lunch.
It was a lunch with a boy,
and I didn't necessarily know
what the vibe was yet,
so I wanted to bring a friend.
-Uh-huh.
-And Timmy was the only person
around, so I brought him.
-Gotcha.
-Which, in hindsight, is maybe
not the most polite thing to do,
because I do think the other boy
might have
liked me a little bit.
-Well, he's probably has
e-mailed you about it.
-Yeah, I know.
[ Laughter ]
-It's just waiting there
to be read.
-I wouldn't know.
I wouldn't know. Don't ask me.
-Exactly.
-Yeah, it's deep down in there.
-Yeah, deep down.
That's just a lost message.
-I know.
-Hey, it's always so great
to see you.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations about the show.
Come back again soon.
-Anytime.
-Kiernan Shipka,
"Swimming With Sharks"
is available on
the Roku channel.
Be right back with music
from Fontaines D.C.